on va distinguer globalement dans les
compagnies pétrolières deux groupes de
compagnies pétrolières en gros il y a
les Européens on va trouver total energy
on va trouver shell British Petroleum et
de l'autre côté les Américains et les
compagnies du Moyen-Orient on va trouver
exon Aramco Pemex parmi les leaders les
premières
Tabl sur le moyen terme on parle ici
d'ici le milieu du siècle sur une baisse
relative de la demande mondiale de
pétrole les seconds à l'inverse sont
toujours sur une trajectoire qui prévoit
une augmentation constante de la demande
de pétrole je pense sincèrement que les
secondes font fausse route et que
l'accord de la COP 28 est en désaccord
complet avec leur stratégie et avec leur
projection à l'inverse il me semble que
les compagnie européenne gignerait
beaucoup à s'affirmer davantage en
leader de la transition énergétique et
que sera non seulement dans l'intérêt du
climat évidemment mais également dans
leur intérêt stratégique en tant
qu'entreprise